this morning we had one of the most
iconic moments in TV with Gary the
history that I genuinely believe will
help tens of thousands of people over
the next decade as this gets populated
sit down get some popcorn really pay
attention [ __ ] man I'm [ __ ] nervous
man don't worry bro we're friends like
shaking and everything I've been
watching you for like three years dude
my wife is watching my mom is probably
watching - so what's up guys holy [ __ ]
tryin to be a man trying to be a man
here bro it doesn't take a man a man
owns his emotions I'm a man out here
talking about compassion sympathy
kindness and love so I'm proud of you
for talking about your nerves I just
want you to hear this clear you can't
imagine how nice that makes me feel I'm
super flattered so I'm so glad it's
humbling you really do change people's
lives dude like I'm sure you know but
like it's like to a whole different
level so thank you I'm 22 I'm married
I've been married for like three years I
just had a baby couple like you know in
January because I'm pretty fulfilled in
that sense you know what I'm saying but
one thing I've always loved to do since
I've been like 13 is like make youtube
videos just because like I have had
rough patches of my life when I was
younger watching people on YouTube like
you know entertaining people like that's
always been like I'm like wow like you
know it's always made me feel good like
I want to do that's for people too and
like my thing is like I love cars like I
like racing I like you know building
racecars and [ __ ] like I have a youtube
channel that I it's been up for like
four years but I've been so inconsistent
you know like I upload and that I
deleted cuz I think the videos aren't
good enough you know just like really
negative and then that's when I started
watching you I was in tech school I feel
like I went to tech school and I did all
that just to prove myself and you know
just kind of be like you know I'm not as
bad as people think you know especially
when your family says you're bad it's
like kind of rough to deal with that you
know it's extremely difficult so it's
really tough yeah I thought I was like
you know I'm gonna do this I graduated
with a 4.0 which I know in tech schools
like now it's only a year and a half so
it's not like too big of a deal bro I
tried my best
don't bring don't undermine your success
yeah I know just some people like I'm
sure like that's the biggest the biggest
issue out of your mouth is the word some
people yeah
don't you have to stop giving a [ __ ]
about these people in the comments and
the ones that are watching yeah that's
true
I always listen very carefully and just
like you hedging the 4.0 based on some
people is the biggest thing we need to
work on on the next 91 years of your
life that's where you're at you gotta
fix that and when I say fix that that
feels too heavy you need to get into a
better relationship with that right
everyone's always gonna have an opinion
yeah no I mean that's that's 100% true
everyone always has something to say
just to kind of lead up to you know what
I think about myself like in the sense
of so like I'm a very negative person
you know what I'm saying like I'm a
negative Nancy kind of guy like
literally I will you're you're sick
you're cynical like you wake up in your
cynical yes like I wake up and I'm like
what can go wrong today you know because
I I've tried Sears ready for this you're
not a negative person you're a scared
person yeah yeah I could definitely
Alexis that that's a big difference bro
for all the people out there that are
watching that are fear that are scared
and fear-based and vulnerable you're not
negative don't demonize yourself you're
actually vulnerable you're not negative
bro I didn't think about it like that
actually I never thought like that's why
we're [ __ ] doing tea with Ken yes yes
I so I'm glad to be out here let me talk
and let me tell you why this is
important Alexis all of a sudden when
you wake up tomorrow and you realize
you're not a negative when somebody
thinks are a negative person that's
devastating yeah you're like I'm bad no
no you're not bad you're hurt yeah yeah
maybe it was something that happened to
me you know what I was younger or
something you're just kind of like
that's that you know where it's like
what's gonna happen today you know like
it's such a bad but like I feel like
that affects me with everything I do
because like when I'm making youtube
videos or like when I'm doing so like
that I'm kind of like you know like all
this is gonna be trashed like this isn't
good enough like you know and just like
I don't know I put myself down a lot and
I'm just like my original question
actually is nothing with what I'm
talking about you know bro this is the
real [ __ ] and like we're here I'm with
you right now I like this talk right now
I really really really like this talk
right now I think you were helping over
the next 10 years because a lot of
people watch this video not when we
Gordon you're about to help a lot of
people I could see in the comments you
literally just helped a lot of people
just in that one moment so let's keep
going I'm telling you that your
self-esteem is vulnerable because to
your point you said it earlier when your
family tells you you're not good you
believe that [ __ ] yeah yeah Bonner
person we need to get out of that does
your family still say that so like as
soon as I started watching your videos
and I know you say not to do this as
much but like I feel like you know I
just tried to cut out negative people
out of my life and just isolate myself
like I do this a lot I've actually never
had any long-term friends like I've
never had a friend that I can be like oh
I've been best friends with this guy for
a long time I think my best friend right
now I would guess is like I've known him
for like a year you know what I'm saying
because like I soon as like someone who
does something well it's like it makes
me feel negative I just kind of like
isolate myself and I pushed everyone
away you know what I'm saying like of
course cuz yours because you're
emotionally soft yeah yeah I can see
that and you're Mendoza line for cutting
someone off is super low like for me my
Mendoza lines super high why do you have
to really really really go somewhere and
I've had a lot of things done to me I
had a friend in college who stole my
Sega Genesis and I still was friends
with him after I found out oh yeah
because I because I knew he was in a bad
spot to do that to me I was erase a rug
in college but other people I know cut
people off because they said something
right the reason you don't have
long-term friendships is because of your
own lack of self esteem and your
inability to rise above when somebody
goes low that was gonna be my thing like
I said I've been watching you for a long
time and I know like you know you
actually always worse than that to be
honest like Waterloo has made me better
like you know more confident in myself
and more like you know I can deal with
that kind of stuff more but I feel like
it takes a long time too because even in
three years of watching you like I'm
still not where I want to be if that
makes any sense like I'm still you know
now like mentally where I want to be it
just stopped being so negative and I
wish and every time something good
happens in my life I'm always like okay
what's gonna happen now like I said you
can ask my wife like I don't get excited
when good things happen because I
automatically think something wrong is
gonna happen right after bro I live with
this my father's got a lot of these
similar
traits bro holy [ __ ] so I understand you
is there anyway like I can you know like
get better at that you know like horse
you just said you got better the last
three years yeah yeah I feel like I have
like I feel like I've gotten better at
like stop fearing about what other
people think about me that's like a big
thing for me like I've gotten way better
at that you know you see how you've got
some some muscle yeah how'd you do that
yeah I worked out play football in high
school yeah that's how you do this yeah
listening to positivity owning your
shortcomings except that you know the
reason I'm talking with such candor here
you know I'm sure some people are
watching like the and Gary's like
exposing his [ __ ] I'm not doing it I
like it I love it it's awesome because
it's empowering when you own your
shortcomings if you can't own your
[ __ ] shortcomings well then you can't
talk about your strikes what I think is
keeping me here with you is my deep
belief that you're on your way because
it's about awareness fact that you have
the strength to come on here with all
these people watching and talk to me
like this actually makes me believe that
you're well on your way because I know a
lot of people who don't yeah I'm just
like trying to like you know like it's
such a bad thing in my life that like
it's like a mental block for everything
I do that it's like man I need to stop
doing this you need to realize that
you're not bad you grew up being told
you were bad and you believed it you
need to realize you're not bad you're
scared right the second you go from I'm
a bad guy I'm a tough guy I'm a negative
guy - I'm a soft guy I'm a vulnerable
guy I'm emotionally like not where I
need to be guy all of a sudden the way
you even look at yourself changes and
then you could start focusing on
building those muscles on that yeah do
you get this feeling that you cut people
off because you don't feel like you get
into this place where you feel like
they're pulling one off on you and you
don't like that yes like I always think
somebody has an angle every time
someone's nice to me I'm like okay
what's your any to do that what do you
offer me
know what I'm saying did you feel that
way about me the first time you saw the
content potentially like what's gonna be
the other shoe like is he gonna try to
sell me a course or what's the [ __ ]
punchline um surprisingly I feel like I
didn't just because like you know like
you were so honest that I feel like you
wouldn't be the type to do that you know
what I'm saying like you're just being
like straight up like off then taking
honest and maybe that's because I was
remote and through right screen and step
all your life possibly you know here's
where I'm trying to get you to go you
need to get into a totally different
place with your self-esteem you need to
love yourself that's why the biggest
moment of this talk was you're not
negative
you're just vulnerable that was during
this moment because when you wake up and
you're like I'm scared today and I need
to get less scared today
that is HUGE HUGE
compared to waking up and saying I'm
negative I'm a bad guy that's a
game-changer Alexis that's a
game-changer yeah it's it's like hard
though like I tried to I really really
like okay like just stop thinking like
that you know like you got this so it's
it's you have to understand it's
ingrained in you so what you need to do
is practice what do I mean by that the
next this one friend you got right now
for a year the first time he does
something that doesn't pop off properly
you have to [ __ ] you have to like
email me or DME or watch this video game
you have to forgive him right yeah
that's yeah that holds grudges broke
grudges are carb that yeah grudges are
[ __ ] garbage grudges are the
execution of a weak man yeah no I I
agree 100% it makes you just you know
makes your life quality go down when you
hold grudges
is your wife positive yes she's like the
complete opposite of me yeah I so agree
[ __ ] I'm that bad should I try to break
here you're not that bad you're not that
bad bro I'm telling you right now we
changed the terminology in your life
[ __ ] will get good you're not that bad
you're that weak you're that scared
you're that soft I totally agree with
you honestly like it's big I want to
change your vernacular because if you do
you'll be a different man yeah it's that
when you're most scared
you try to bring her down to your level
yeah that's exactly what I do that's
what when you say you talk about like
haters you know like trying to bring
other people down do you find you find
yourself like being jealous if like
another guy looks at her like are you
trying to like cage her no not like that
like I'm not like bad like that but I'm
bad in the sense of like when she's like
trying to be happy for me for something
I accomplished or positive or she's like
don't want to do that don't do that
because I'm gonna something's gonna
happen and then yes you down and that's
gonna be yes
like that's my fear like let my son down
let her down like I'm always like right
bro listen to me the only thing that you
can do to let them down is by continuing
down the path of thinking that you're
bad right yeah yeah I can't I don't want
him to grow up like that you know like
being like me like I don't know where
she don't but let me tell you because
I've watched this I've watched this
transpire cuz I'm cuz I'm old for 44 I
got some real [ __ ] emotional wisdom
what's gonna end up happening is if your
child or children end up having similar
DNA to you you're gonna feel so bad that
you're gonna actually resent them and
have like a worse relation like you'll
have a good relationship with the
children that take your wife's DNA and
you'll have a bad relationship with the
children that take your DNA cuz it's
gonna be painful to you because you may
be like [ __ ] I pass that on to her or
him so I'm out no I can't do that you
can't do that yeah bro I'm really proud
of you to be at this place at this young
of an age to be self-aware enough to
know what's brewing and to have the
courage to come on here and talk to me
about this [ __ ] that's going changing
you okay when I tell you you're close
because the only thing that holds people
back is hiding [ __ ] right right and
right now you just told tens of
thousands of people about your [ __ ] yeah
yeah it's just like that bad dude like
I'm like I have to tell someone that
actually like you know cuz I got to tell
other people like my wife I want to say
other people I mean like my wife she's
just like I feel like maybe hearing it
from her is not as good because I'm I of
course you're just gonna try to like you
know bring me up and make me feel better
because I'm your husband you know so of
course like I feel like her answer is
not as genuine maybe but it probably
carries automatically think that yeah
you listen you default into the anger
the conspiracy you must love conspiracy
[ __ ] documentaries like you that's
like you know like like that's where
you're at
yeah and what's so interesting in the
theme of this show is now you know why
you're the one that looks at other
things and tries to tear people down
yeah yeah I all the same game I really
believe as we go through this period of
time in American history specifically
and really in the world where hate and
negativity have definitely risen or not
I believe that we're gonna get into
mental health issues and get into you
know parenting structures and like what
I'm really worried about is that a lot
of people that are that think they're
kind and good people are actually
shaming people in start instead of
trying to help right yeah I agree with
that
I think or she did there on the
receiving end of that yes yes yeah yeah
I think I gotta like work on it more
like on a daily basis and just exercise
it more I don't know I didn't think
about it like I'm scared of stuff you
know I just thought about it like i'm
just- you know and like i just don't
like people that much you know and this
and that you know no you don't like
yourself yeah yeah no that's probably
you don't like I really don't like how I
like I hate that that's right but the
good news is you can fix it I didn't
like that I didn't have you know muscles
and you know like and that I was not
healthy for my heart and like I was
gonna like and I changed it and when I
tell you working out and eating right
did not come natural to me at all so I
changed I figured it out I got a
babysitter a trainer and I figured out
the system you just have to figure out
your system maybe you have to listen to
positivity on podcast 24 hours of that's
what I use all every single day like oh
and other people too I appreciate it but
like you know like bro you have to watch
this video like every day ya know I
probably this is like the biggest moment
like top five like best things like in
my learning bro you are just perfectly
cliche in so many your actions I see so
many young people who have this
framework get married early as soon as
they find somebody super positive yeah
yeah it's not even realize it
yeah it's right first for her yeah I
really I told her like I wish I could be
like you like I wish I could just think
everything's gonna be fine and like you
know like I
we saw that because it's just such a
good you know like you know instead of
making it selfish and say I wish I could
be like you maybe what you can do is
make it accomplished you're making it
about yourself when you say that to her
well sure but you might want to change
that too and this is where semantics of
words matter maybe you say to her what's
her name
oh no I mean no I mean I admire your
optimism and positivity now all of a
sudden you're giving her a compliment
because when you say to her
I wish that I could be like you she's
not taking that as a compliment she sees
that as you being selfish about what you
wish you're about you in that sentence
yeah that's true
yeah I'm saying I wish I was you know
yeah and what you're doing is you're
subconsciously again saying hey like
feel bad for me right
instead of propping her up you're asking
her for another hand there's a
subconscious guilt of like you got lucky
with DNA I didn't and what's gonna
happen with her she's gonna build
resentment for you over time right
bro I really really believe in you Thank
You Man I appreciate it like you know I
don't normally talk about this with
anyone
you know normally like I tried like I
said like only with her but I was like
man Gary's like the perfect person you
just put this on you know and just see
like what you know what his response
would be I swear to God on everything in
my body I genuinely think you can win
this game
thank you man I really like it's
life-changing to hear that from you know
what I'm saying like it's so please
realize that you were wound you're hurt
you're not bad
you're good with an injury right yeah I
just didn't realize that I didn't think
about it I didn't I didn't you know I
guess I guess cuz I'm young too so it
kind of like you don't think about that
stuff like you know and now I'm like
damn that's probably what it is maybe
something happened to me you know like
it just kind of like yeah but like don't
and I don't think it's usually it's more
of a systematic you know culture like
it's very likely that one of your
parents is exactly the same way and
instead of resent in your parent you can
feel bad for them too right you can have
compassion for
then instead of now going into a place
of like you know what [ __ ] you mom Gary
he's right I'm [ __ ] you no no you can go
into a place of compassion because it's
likely that her mom did that or your
dad's dad did that you understand yeah
yeah you need to realize that you're
strong enough to change it for everyone
digging in and drawing a line and making
it a fight is gonna do nothing yeah and
you think like also like what you
surround yourself with also kind of
affects you too 100% it's why I [ __ ]
worked so hard to put out so much free
content I'm trying to be a positive
force for people that aren't fortunate
enough to have something and I have a
unique communication style and a and a
human element that clicks for some
people that because because I think they
can taste the lack of interest of
anything other than the X you know like
I'm not looking for anything I agree
100% that's what I said when I first
started watching your videos I didn't
think like you've had an angle I feel
like I was like holy [ __ ] this guy's
like and it's I think it's cuz you
called people in their [ __ ] you know
and like funny you know xx hear that a
lot from me from people and they like
that you know what's funny I think even
the tone of this conversation I just
want to help right like I said even in
three years I feel like I have gotten
better you know maybe I've gotten worse
actually that isolate people like myself
from people more but I have gotten
better in the sense of like you know now
like with YouTube and like other stuff
like that I'm more confident that I will
be able to make that work you know like
that's like my other thing that I like
you you need to realize that those
people aren't bad or have an angle it's
that you're scared cuz you're not
emotionally strong to be let down yeah
they're cutting you're cutting them out
to protect yourself the way to really
win quote-unquote is for you to get
comfortable with being let down and
realizing that's not a reflection of you
right no I agree with that that's that's
awesome that's like what I needed to
keep I could deliver it bro thank you so
much man I really really appreciate it
dude
let's listen to me over the next year a
million people gonna watch this video
just remember that means that cutting
people
or trolling someone or waking up like
you're not going to be able to live
anymore tricking people you're not
tricking anyone anymore right
use that as a positive yeah I need to
change I need to do something like I
can't keep being like this this is I'm
telling you right now what most excites
me is I know you can thank you so much
if you knew the power and strength it
took for you to be honest on this video
now living life and being ok with Ricki
if you like steals your money or like
says something bad about your wife and
you being a bigger person like you can't
imagine now trying to forgive one of
your parents or an uncle or some you
know I don't want to dive too deep it
might be something even more extreme
than just a negative atmosphere there
might be some real deep [ __ ] forgiveness
is the [ __ ] key to a whole new life
yeah no I I haven't practiced that yet
in my life if you know like I have it
really I'm not a forgetful person so
maybe I should comes that comes out of
your own insecurity yeah forgiveness and
being the bigger person and kindness is
the [ __ ] ultimate strength yeah no
that's yeah I need that I need to do it
I didn't start doing it I really do I
really believe you I really think you
can I really think you can it's one five
minutes late for a huge client meet oh
my god no no what I'm what I want you to
hear is that the reason I'm this late is
because I feel this moment so much and
I'm also super aware of how raw and real
we went and how many hundreds of people
right now watching or live in your exact
life and this this thing I genuinely
believe is the seed of so much of the
things that are anxious in our society
and I desperately desperately want to be
one of the forces to [ __ ] help cut
this thing out of our bodies ya know I
mean we need it you know like the people
that are like Alexis you have an
Instagram yes because I want this
community DM you encourage you and I
want you to make some positive friends
what's your what's your soul
um it's Alexis sis narrow
Yeah right there somebody found or
doesn't found it I guess that's all so
holy [ __ ] sorry yes you are 567 568 now
I'll be like how much you like cars I
love cars that's been my passion since I
was like six years old
alright 568 vaynernation this would mean
the world to me I want to see this
number completely [ __ ] explode and I
want every one of you to DM this man
something positive
I want please please thank you so much I
appreciate that so much Gary man thank
you so much Lexus listen to me please do
me one honor please listen to this whole
entire thing I think it was like 30
minutes it's often off okay thank you so
much like literally work out every
morning and listen to this where while
you're brushing their teeth every
morning every morning I'm telling you
man yeah thank you so much dude I will
listen to it I mean trust me this is
like a huge deal to me like like I said
it's a huge it's a huge deal for me too
thank you so much holy [ __ ] like I
didn't I honestly wasn't even going to
talk to you about this like I was like I
had a whole different question but then
I was like talking to you I'm like damn
like he's actually like as real as it
gets man you know so I was like you know
I'm just gonna lay it all out you know
Alexis you helped more people today than
most people ever get to help in their
entire life you're a good kid you're not
negative you're not bad
they were mislabeled bro you make me cry
dude like well you're mislabeled you're
miss labeling yourself to yourself yeah
you're a wonderful [ __ ] human who has
an injury has a vulnerability and has to
completely address that and change the
way you talk and think and practice that
you want you want a real prescription go
reach out to everybody in your phone go
to your phone right now and look at from
A to Z and text people and say you're
sorry and I love you yeah that takes
real strength yeah yeah yeah there's
some people that I'm like you know I
would never want to see this guy's name
again I don't know why like it's because
because you're insecure yeah
and when you do that if you get the
courage to do it when
replied [ __ ] you understand yeah
compassion comes from enormous strength
thank you so much man like like I said
this is this moment right here I think
it was definitely a hundred percent
life-changing for me this is definitely
like like I said I've been doing better
in these last three years but I feel
it's you like that boost that I need a
hundred percent thank you so much I love
you I'm so sorry luck thank you so much
me I love you too sorry for what
sorry for you be late this is the best
nine minutes late in my entire life I'm
so humbled to have this moment with you
what we just did here will forever bring
value to human beings I believe it in
the depths of my [ __ ] being thank you
dude that's like that means the world to
me that honestly it really means the
world to me dude this is what I needed
thank you so much Barry you're welcome
brother
that's great day man thank you too bye
bye Dustin that really matters that last
one man yeah I know
like that's the whole game that right
there was the whole game I see in the
world I feel very similar like there's a
lot of people in my world that I've kind
of dropped and I've wanted to reach out
I'm just afraid that they're gonna be
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you are like whatever
loser or something like that right I
just don't know that well that don't do
things for other people's reactions do
them for you and for the Karma and even
if they tell you [ __ ] you they'll always
know where you stood cuz right now they
think you stand with [ __ ] you and you
might be doing a blessing for them
because that may inspire them to do it
for somebody else even if they don't
reply to you yeah there's nothing more
noble than I'm sorry
[Applause]
and if you can do in an audio or video
where they can not lose the tone of the
written word but it's even more powerful
than just you can do it or you're here
with me now like come on you can do that
should yeah you're right it's good
putting out more good is good you know
it's what we [ __ ] need man this is
it's time we've gone too long with not
making this the way we go you're gonna
feel lighter I mean I did start like I
had someone left me something to like
make fun of someone and I was like i DM
them and like hey someone sent this to
me to like make fun of you and I was
like no I'm not doing that like I
actually respect what you just put out
and so I just want to say that and any
bad taste you having about me from the
past I just want to apologize for that
too
I mean I didn't reply but at least
things no no no not tried executed
you're not doing it for him to reply you
brought value to him and you brought
value to yourself you won with that I'm
so proud of you man that's a humongous
thanks right down the list from [ __ ]
a A to Z Z and you're in your address
book write down the list the watch boy
listen
that means you were hurting yeah I know
you well enough to understand it do it
it's so nice to do it's so good you're a
different man now
yeah
see tomorrow until Gary day
you